[Musique]
pas d'affolement le dernier épisode vous
sera livré en français même si vous
venez de surprendre une simulation
réceptionniste cliente en anglais à deux
pas d'une boutique tourisme plus vraie
que nature on a la chance d'avoir cet
espace qui est un lieu pédagogique tant
pour faire des mises en situation que
pour la partie agencement puisque les
les étudiants à tour de rôle à partir
d'un thème qu'on leur donne doivent
complètement agancer cette cette
boutique qui est qui est pour le
tourisme face à face dans ce décor
reconstitué une élève interprète la
conseilère et l'autre la cliente à
décise j'adore c'est vraiment quelque
chose que j'attend souvent j'aime
beaucoup mettre en scène et jouer un
rôle que je suis pas le rôle de
quelqu'un que je suis pas d'habitude
donc c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup
faire les mises en situation bien
évidemment je connais n pas le profil
client que je vais avoir en face de moi
ce qui joue aussi dans l'improvisation
après du scénario de vente mais ça
demande quand même un gros travail de
recherche avant et pendant ce temps-là
en salle c'est l'heure d'une étrange
chorégraphie poser la
fourchette poser le couteau couver
prendre l'assiette preuve que le
professeur est bien dans son assiette
une autre boutique celle-ci n'est plus
virtuelle elle porte le nom de VAE venta
emporté et au milieu de la matinée on y
fait la queue c'est agréable mais
parfois c'est vraiment rapide il faut on
a que à peine 10 minutes pour que les
clients viennent et repartent donc il
faut vraiment être très rapide pour
vendre tous ces pains au chocolat et
tous ces croissants donc c'est assez
difficile et éprouvant donc l'idée c'est
de pouvoir faire en sorte de
commercialiser son produit et puis en
parallèle donc nous avons des élèves qui
sont en première année de bétesse
hôtellerie et qui ici euh chaque semaine
euh tourne de façon à ce qu'il puisse
tenir donc le point de vente avec des
contrôles de caiss qui sont fait voilà
et l'idée c'est de pouvoir leur dire
vous êtes responsable d'un magasin en
une semaine et surtout donc gérer les
production F mesure justement la
production ce sera notre dernière escale
la brigade des boulangers pâtissiers
rivalise d'adresse avec l'école des
beauarts la preuve à la poche et sur
fond de macaron c'est son chef qui nous
offre le mot de la
fin